yogurt and welcome to this video playing
skipper skipper deep from from Germany d
formal and c3 yeah this is one of them
super solid ways to start a game just
setting up something like the Torah
opening or the Trump offski Queen a3 is
funny maybe thinking that I would play
Bishop e7 on a pre move other than that
the move doesn't really make much sense
when you can set up your pieces like
that but it's certainly not the best way
to play I want to try to play a cookie 5
against that and i'm preparing that
right now the Queen on a three neglects
the e5 square you really wanted knight
on f3 to make sure if I the subplate
so I'll play five next move pretty much
no matter what he's doing yeah maybe
Bishop f4 or something uh-huh yeah I can
play you five anyway let's say 92 our
play five takes energy form
yeah if he takes as much energy for wow
I didn't think he could could take I
mean this already looks a very nice for
black and threatening Knight e5 winning
hmm yeah you can't plagued you can play
g5 you can play night after I thought g5
here my god you got Queenie to okay okay
just just take it it's it's good for
black anyway don't need to do anything
anything too fancy this is just a
position where I've got the bishop pair
and on g7 and b7 they will will appear
ya know is even allowing me we should be
four amongst others yeah okay I do that
hmm yeah maybe this is the relatively
best way to play try to to use the D
file
midd 54 in this somewhat we care
okay this is very very direct and
probably loses a poem but I don't really
want to care about about the deep own so
all the time so this is justice just
accept the fact that it might might get
lost but stays active
yeah probably just yell exactly King be
one
queen is 79 s95
okay didn't really intended to do that
but maybe I need to yet so fairly fairly
good for black i mean the the bishops
and so on but I really thought I was
some almost winning before and this
didn't really materialize the unknown
castles was a quite quite a problem yeah
threatening 25 but this is very easy to
see but the Lucas could only eight
anyway ok now it's not really doing much
if I if I take in the queen is so Cabot
now
yeah just just go back I don't know
there's some many ways to play yeah f5
assume is now a threat yeah we should be
five but then I have to be born it's
still fairly a fairly nice for black I
think it's very good compensation for
the porn but I must have done something
wrong before to to even allow that I
think white plate really too many bad
moves to to stay in the game okay before
yeah guess so now there's no check
anymore f5 person is a good idea so this
night it can take on before it can take
on B form
I but I can take on in situ actually and
Bishop f4 check check be 325 take screen
82 as winning for black it sounds I made
even I think
and if we give moves the King I can even
think about just taking the roof yeah
this is maybe even better
yeah p 3 25 s are just immediately over
white resigned yeah there's nothing left
it goes him i can i can simply take here
and have an extra piece something like
that the only it was really strange
after the opening because he played so
many strange moves that I thought okay
black shirt should be winning here here
I thought g5 at first but I think this
is this is ok but here he and around him
that's the way to does there's a spot to
turn boom maybe this after long castles
wasn't so great i mean this d5 pawn is
is weak and ike i need to improve on
that the thing is blacks got two bishops
and central edge so like has a clear
advantage already the question is how to
to play here the computer wants to go g5
and now that I look at it I had the idea
but I didn't really think this through
this is this is really good actually can
I do that because of Bishop g4 so he
needs to go back to h3 which is damn
ugly and now the compounds to play a
five intending to take a plane Bishop
basics yeah this is something not bad at
all besides that um I think okay I can
think about that but not sure that this
at first looks nice with the porn but
yeah this would be excellent with the
pawn on d6 but here they are still black
is better maybe this is indeed good
taking a bishop a6 is strong let's say
something like that
yeah and I stay with oops not this one
with 22 great bishops yeah and the game
it wasn't so clear actually it's it's
still okay probably after the spawn loss
the thing is black black has still good
pieces the two bishops are strong and
those pieces don't really have good
squares here there were various ways to
to get get a good game and here it is
just it's winning I think the screen f3
movers I mean okay you can probably play
that but you need to correct immediately
now as like as started threatening five
maybe queen somewhere and then control
we five alright thanks for watching